chers collègues nous accueillons à
présent Monsieur Serge Lecomte président
de la Fédération française d'équitation
et Monsieur Frédéric brick délégué
général messieurs je vous souhaite la
bienvenue et vous remercie de votre
disponibilité pour répondre à nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de cette commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet nos travaux
portent sur trois axes les violences
physiques sexuelle ou psychologique dans
le sport les discriminations sexuelles
et raciales et les problématiques liées
à la gouvernance financière des
organisme de gouvernance du monde
sportif monsieur le Président en 1987
vous êtes élu vice-président de la
Fédération française d'équitation et
occuper cette fonction jusqu'en 2004
date à laquelle vous êtes élu président
de la Fédération vous aviez déjà été élu
président de la Fédération une première
fois en 2003 mais votre élection avait
été annulée pour pour non respect des
quotas des représentants du milieu
professionnel vous êtes élu en 2008 en
2012 en 2016 et en 2021 en 2011 vous
êtes renvoyé devant le tribunal
correctionnel pour prise illégale
d'intérêt il vous est reproché d'avoir
octroyer un financement de 2005 d'euros
de la FFE au syndicat groupement ipique
national alors que vous étiez président
de ce syndicat sur la même période
couverte le TGI de Paris reconnaîtra en
2013 que l'infraction était constituée
vous dispense de peine en 2020 mdiapart
révèle plusieurs fait plusieurs affaires
d'agression sexuelle sur mineur dans le
milieu équestre dont l'une concernant lï
CODAL en 2013 monsieur CODAL alors
directeur du centre équaisse de Suren
avait été condamné pour atteinte
sexuelle sur mineur de 15 ans mdiapart
indique que vous étiez au courant du
passé de de pédocriminalité de
de Monsieur CODAL mais que vous lui
auriez pourtant proposé un emploi dans
lequel il pouvait être en contact de
jeunes mineurs de 2014 à 2019 il vous
est reproché de n'avoir pris aucune
mesure disciplinaire à l'encontre de
Monsieur CODAL ni à l'égard du centre
équestre de Suren en 2020 la cavaliière
Amélie kanginer kgin dénonce des viols
subis au cours de son enfance au
du milieu équestre et l'action
insuffisante des instances dirigeantes
en
2021 alors que Madame keginer dénonce
une omerta dans le sport équestre et
l'absence de mesures prises par la
Fédération pour lutter contre les
violences la FF l'attaque pour
diffamation avant de retirer sa plainte
3 ans après son premier témoignage
madame keginer se plaint encore d'une
fédération qui ne s'engage pas pour
aider les victimes ni pour éloigner les
prédateurs présumés de nouvelles
victimes
potentielles la Fédération Française
équitation fait partie des quatre
fédérations sur lesquelles madame
maracinaanou nous a dit avoir enquêté
demander une enquête par par
l'igsr Monsieur le Délégué Général vous
êtes employé par la FFE depuis plus de
20 ans vous y avez été en chargé de
mission directeur du tourisme équestre
chargé de mission auprès du président
avant d'être nommé délégué général en
2012 vous êtes par ailleurs président de
la Fédération internationale de tourisme
équestre depuis
2015 messieurs dans un bref
proposliminaire pouvez-vous revenir sur
les faits que je viens de rappeler et
nous dire quelles sont les conclusions
de la mission de contrôle diligentée par
la ministre sur votre fédération je
rappelle que cette audition est ouverte
à la presse et qu'elle est retransmise
en direct sur le le site de l'Assemblée
nationale avant de vous laisser la
parole et d'entamer nos échanges je vous
rappelle que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
entendues par une commission d'enquête
de prêter cement de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité je vous
invite donc à lever la main droite
chacun à votre tour et à dire je le jure
après avoir activé votre
micro je jure micro s'il vous
plaît vous appuyez devant je le jure
désactiver voilà je le jure merci vous
avez la parole et bien sûr je tiens à
excuser tous mes collègues du retard euh
de la demi-heure de retard par rapport à
à l'heure d'audition Merci à VOUS
oui oui dans ce que vous venez de
rapporter il y a beaucoup de vérité et
beaucoup de vérité qui a été euh
refabriqué donc ça me semble compliqué
de revenir point par point sur tous les
sujets qui ont été abordés mais ceci dit
euh euh il y a aucun il y a aucun sujet
tabou et comme il y a beaucoup de sujets
très différents euh je vais pas prendre
la parole pendant une demi-heure pour
tous les reprendre les uns après les
autres c'est le temps minimum qu'il me
faudrait tous ces sujetsl ont été
largement déjà évoqués euh je voudrais
peut-être juste en revenir sur le le
dernier élément avec le ministre des
Sports précédent euh où
euh je pense que le fait que la
Fédération française d'équitation était
particulièrement visée par des violences
sexuelles est très excessif et on a un
certain nombre d'éléments d'ailleurs
pour expliquer très clairement très
ouvertement ce qui s'est passé ou non le
le les les différents sujets que vous
avez abordé ils ont tous été devant un
tribunal ils ont tous été dé c certains
jugés d'autres avec des sentences qui
ont été exécutées donc j'ai pas
grandchose de plus à y
ajouter monsieur BX vous voulez rajouter
autre
chose je n'ai rien à ajouter de de
répondre à vos à vos questions sur ces
différents dossiers en fonction des des
pièces dont j'ai
connaissance
ok
euh peut-être du coup on va revenir
sur l'affaire Serge lecte euh
donc dans cette affaire vous vous
défendez de ne pas avoir été mis au
courant des événements vous avez indiqué
d'ailleurs que vous n'étiez pas
informé des faits à cette période là
est-ce que vous maintenez ces
déclarations du fait que au moment où
vous l'avez embauché à la FFE vous
n'étiez pas informé des faits qui lui
était
reproché dans cette affaire il y a eu
une enquête de l'inspection générale qui
n'a eu de cess que d'essayer de
disculper les suffisance de
l'administration donc j'ai pas à revenir
dessus ils en ont fait un rapport je
l'ai contesté en tant que tel à la fin
de de de cette enquête
euh les allégations du journalistes qui
vous laissent faire un président de plus
sont uniquement une des vérités qui ont
été découpées en morceau et reconstitué
j'ai rien à ajouter à ce dossier-là et
c'est pas une affaire vous parlez d'une
affaire c'est pas une affaire euh
lorsque j'ai
connu la la décision du tribunal
d'interdire ce
salarié d'enseigner il était déjà
convenu depuis longtemps qu'on se sépare
il a répondu à une offre d'emploi de la
Fédération comme chauffeur qui n'avait
rien à voir avec le contact de mineur en
particulier d'autant plus que la
Fédération prend jamais en charge de
mineur donc voilà tout est dit
mais je pourrais revenir sur les
infivances de l'administration à cet
égard si vous le souhaitez alors
justement parce que vous vous avez
commencé donc alors ce que je comprends
c'est est-ce que vous remettez en cause
le rapport de
l'inspection dans le fait qu'ils ont
voulu vous avez utilisé le mot disculper
l'administration tout à fait donc voilà
est-ce que je met en cause le rapport
dans son ensemble mais tout à fait
l'idée de l'inspection c'était de
disculper l'administration les choses
sont très simples euh euh j'ai un
établissement écaisse dans les hautes
scènes ce n'est pas le siège social
l'administration des hautes scènes avait
pour habitude de m'envoyer mes courriers
au siège social qui est dans le valdoise
et au sujet de l'interdiction de
Monsieur CODAL avec lequel j'avais
terminé d'ailleurs les liens de de
subordination en tant que salarié ils
ont tout simplement envoyé une lettre
sans sans nomination au centre équaisse
directement monsieur le Président lettre
simple euh n recommandé
et et envoyé à Suren il faut savoir que
à Suren il y avait déjà deux
présidents monsieur CODAL président du
comité départemental d'équitation et le
président de l'association qui siège à
Suren donc ils ont pris la lettre qui
leur été
dessiné monsieur le Président centre
équestre voilà et puis et puis voilà et
puis les choses sont aussi simples que
ça
et le l'objectif de l'enquête ça a été
de dire l'administration a bien fait son
boulot ben non elle a pas fait son
boulot elle avait qu'à me prévenir par
l'être recommandé directement au siège
social à l'adresse à laquelle ils avait
l'habitude de
m'écrire mais ça aurait rien changé
puisque mes mes mes relations de travail
était déjà terminé quand je l'ai
appris alors ce que vous nous dites
c'est qu'au moment où vous apprenez les
affaires concernant l'icodel il n'était
déjà plus
salarié de la Fédération non pour
d'autres raisons on avait convenu
d'arrêter no nos relations de travail
j'embauchais un couple le coupe ne
fonctionnait plus et entre les deux on
avait décidé de garder sa compampagne
qui travaillait également dans
centrequeste depuis des
années peut-être même question parce que
selon nos information vous étiez
Monsieur Frédéric Bou en charge des
embauches et donc c'est vous-même qui
auriez recruté monsieur
CODAL est-ce que vous vous étiez informé
des condamnations qui le concernaent non
effectivement j'étais chargé des
embauches comme le président l'a rappelé
monsieur CODAL a répondu à une offre
d'emploi comme agent d'entretien pour
mission de chauffeur on a un camion
événementiel qui se déplace sur sur nos
événements majeurs et donc monsieur
CODAL a été recruté en CDD dans ce cadre
là le 12 juin 2014 en CDD qui ont été
renouvelés avant de de se transformer en
CDI et nous l'avons appris en tous les
cas pour ma part bien plus tard par par
son épouse qui était également salarié à
la Fédération à partir de de 2015 et
c'est comme ça qu'on a appris bien plus
tard mais quand je dis bien plus tard
c'est plusieurs années après euh les
condamnations de Monsieur
CODAL alors vous avez évoqué euh le
journaliste en tout cas le l'article de
méia part
euh voilà
euh lui il indique que vous étiez au
courant du passé alors pourquoi
justement enfin alors voilà comment lui
il arrive à demander à lui hein faut lui
demander comment il il peut peut
affirmer que j'étais au courant du passé
mais euh est-ce que vous connaissez le
jugement en question de loï CODAL le
contenu du jugement vous le
connaissez bon non vous allez nous le
dire donc on parle de non non moi je
j'ai pas vous donner la teneur du du
jugement vous pouvez le vous en rendre
compte mais là on parle d'une affaire
donc personne connaît le contenu
hein ça se résume pas ça le le jugement
il y a a il y a d'autres éléments qui
voilà
alors soit vous soit vous nous dites ce
qu'il y est exactement dedans soit en
fait parce que nous ce qu'on a c'est
atteinte sexuelle sur mineur de 15 ans
c'est écrit donc il y a pas
de de 15 ans il y a écrit depu 15
ans non mais voyez faut lire le jugement
franchement faut lire le jugement pour
en parler si vous avez pas lu le
jugement c'est c'est un vrai sujet alors
en fait la question c'est pas si on a lu
le jugement ou pas on est là pour vous
poser des questions donc moi je vous
pose la question sur comment le
journaliste indique puisqu'il fait un
article où il dit que vous étiez au
courant
alors alors dans le cadre de l'enquête
qui a été mené est-ce que vous n'avez
jamais été entendu par la justice par
exemple sur cette affaire j'ai j'ai j'ai
été entendu par la suite
par le poste de police sur un certain
nombre de questions je saurais pas me
dire je saurais pas vous dire ce que
mais je sais que le le le le le
compte-rendu de mon audition c'est s'est
promené un petit peu donc mais
franchement il faudrait que je l'ISS
sous les yeux pour me rappeler ce que
j'ai dit ce dont j'ai parlé mais me
demandez pas comment assu le journaliste
il me l'a jamais dit je l'ai jamais vu
j'ai jamais rencontré je l'ai eu 2
minutes au téléphone et j'ai vu tout de
suite qu'il essayait de faire une
enquête à charge sans sans sans savoir
les tenants et les aboutissants de cette
affaire donc en tant que président du
club de Suren vous n'avez jamais été
entendu en tant que témoin dans cette
affaire je suis pas président du club de
Suren je suis gérant d'une société ce
qui n'a rien à voir avec la Fédération
d'un établissement équestre qui est qui
est une de ses activités à sur ok et
vous n'avez jamais été entendu dans ce
cadre là j'ai été entendu je vous viens
de vous le dire pas par la justice par
je vous parle avant d'être informé non
non bien sûr j'ai su mais c'est cette
cette audition c'est c'est bien après le
départ de de de
loïodal et je dois dire que puisque moi
j'ai quand même lu les jugements il y a
eu un deuxième jugement pour une
soi-disante récidive qu'on a qu'on qu'on
qu'on
qu'on qu'on est explique que c'est à la
fédération qui aurait fait une récidive
mais en réalité c'est une récidive qui a
eu lieu avant le premier jugement donc
qui n'a rien à voir avec sa présence à
la Fédération donc je comprends pas
c'est quoi enfin qu'est-ce que vous
contestez Vous contestez le jugement le
fait mais vous dites soit-disant une
récidive oui parce que le journaliste
dont vous me parlez a expliqué qu'il y a
eu une récidive ensuite à la Fédération
ce qui n'est pas le cas il n'y a pas eu
de récidive à la Fédération ce deuxième
jugement puisqu'il a été condamné deux
fois c'est des faits qui sont passés à
avant le la première affaire donc qui
n'a rien à voir avec sa présence à la
Fédération voilà c'est tout ce que je
vous dis hein je conteste rien du tout
les choses sont faites depuis longtemps
ils ont été largement débattus donc j'ai
rien à contester monsieur le Président
je voudrais vous dire que nous ne sommes
pas un tribunal d'accord madame la
rapporteur et moi-même et mes collègues
députés ici présents nous avons souhaité
vous entendre au cours de cette
commission d'enquête comme je vous l'ai
dit dans les propos liimminires qui
travaillent donc sur trois axes qui nous
paraissent importants et notamment les
dysfonctionnements pour les les bien sûr
relever et constater ces
dysfonctionnement pour pouvoir améliorer
toutes les conditions qui permettent en
tout cas à nos à nos à aux mineurs et
peut-être même aussi aux adultes
d'ailleurs de pratiquer le sport dans
toute sécurité donc nous vous convions
pas comme un comme un comme un accusé
voilà mais plutôt comme un président de
fédération pour apporter bien sûr votre
expérience professionnelle au auprès de
cette commission d'enquête pour que nous
puissions au même titre que tous les
précédents qui les présidents qui vous
ont précédé et qui vous suivront demain
et bien on puisse travailler ensemble en
toute connaissance de cause donc vous
n'êtes pas au tribunal donc on vous pose
les questions gentiment sincèrement en
toute simplicité on espère juste avoir
des réponses dans le même sens j'observe
madame la Présidente que les questions
dont vous posz concernent rien la
fédération
néanmoins il vous concerne vous en tant
que président de la Fédération pas en
tant que pas en tant que mes action
auprès de la
Fédération est-ce qu'à l'époque vous
aviez été reçu par la ministre des
Sports sur cette
affaire pouvez nous dire lors de cette
rencontre ce qui a été décidé ce qui
s'est dit il s'est rien décidé du tout
on a eu une inspection générale quelques
temps après on était en période
électorale et je pense que cette affaire
là a été uniquement instrumentalisée par
les uns et par les autres à des fins
électorales sur la la les élections de
la Fédération française
d'équitation et il en est de même des
autres déclarations en particulier de
Madame
kegener alors peut-être pour l'année
euh combien de cases vous avez examiné
en commission disciplinaire et quelles
décisions euh ont été prises suite à ces
commissions
je vais je vais vous répondre j'ai le le
détail de des travaux donc en 2023 il
n'y a pas eu
de la commission disciplinaire ne s'est
pas réuni pour des sujets liés au au
violence sexuel elle le fera en début
d'année 2024 avec deux dossiers en cours
elle l'avait fait une fois en 2018 5
fois en 2021 et deux fois en 2022
OK et quand il y a eu ces commission de
disciplinaire est- quelles ont été les
décisions qui ont été prises sur les
différentes affaires en question même
s'il en a pas eu forcément 2023 parce
que je comprends qu'en 2023 il y en a eu
zéro non c'est 2022 oui 2023
c'est4 2023 c'est pour 2024 donc elle
s'est pas réunie en 2023 sur elle s'est
réunie pour d'autres affaires sur des
sujets liés au VSS il n'y a pas eu de
décision de la commission juridique et
disciplinaire de la fédération en 2023
sur que ce soit sur sur le le millésim
2023 je vous dis il y en a eu une en
2018 si vous voulez la nature de la de
la sanction je peux vous la donner une
en 2018 avec une suspension de
compétition de 6 mois sur un sportif en
2021 il y en a eu 5 une avec une
suspension de licence pendant 15 ans une
avec une suspension de licence jusqu'à
une décision judiciaire
définitive une avec un surc à statuer
jusqu'à une décision
judiciaire une autre une suspension de
licence de compétition pour une période
de 5 ans dont 2 ans avec surc et une
autre avec une suspension d'un an de
fonction d'organisateur de compétition
en 2022 il y a eu une relaxe et une
ension de 3 ans de fonction d'officielle
de compétition dont 2 ans et demi avec
surc et comme je vous l' indiquéis
plusieurs dossiers sont en cours pour le
début de l'année 2024 avec une
commission juridique déjà saisie et sur
les sanctions qui ont été prononcées de
quel type d'affairire est-ce qu'on parle
c'est des VSS mais de quoi on parle
exactement j'ai pas le détail complet
des cas que je pourrais vous vous
communiquer si vous souhaitez de nature
très différente effectivement allant de
propos de propos jusqu'à à des actes de
violence et est-ce que ces décision ont
été publiée au Bulletin
officiel ces décisions sauf avis
contraire de la la commission car le la
publication relève de décisions de la
commission elles ont été publié
effectivement dans le magazine qui
s'appelle l'ARF dès lors qu'elles sont
définitives c'est-à-dire que les les
recours possibles dans le cas des
instances fédéral et des éventuels
recours en conciliation sont purgés donc
les sanctions définitives sont publiées
sauf décision contraire donc de
l'instance disciplinaire qui le précise
dans son
jugement notamment pour des affaires qui
les noms de les noms de mineurs peuvent
être on va dire masqués de certains
jugements sur un autre sujet une
sousreésentation systématique voir une
absence des oppositions au sein du
comité fédéral de la Fédération est
constaté depuis de nombreuses années
cela permet peut-être une efficacité à
la prise de décision mais prive la
fédération de débats contradictoires
potentiel fructueux cette situation est
largement défavorisée par les statuts de
la
fédération favorisé pardon pourquoi
fonctionner
ainsi écoutez vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure du fait que j'avais été élu en
2003 et ensuite sous administration
judiciaire donc avec mon élection qui
était cassée
le le vrai la vraie raison de cette
cette procédure qui a lieu à l'époque
c'est que il y avait deux tenants du
projet fédéral les uns avec des
élections aux grands électeurs comme
c'était le cas dans la plupart des
fédérations et les autres avec une
élection avec la base c'estàd avec les
adhérents de la Fédération que sont les
groupements sportifs on a largement
débattu sur ces ces statuts les statuts
ont été à l'époque imposés par le
ministère des sports avec un contenu et
avec de des des administrateur bien
précis bien définis le la seconde
version bien sûr elle a été soumis en
assemblée générale par l'administrateur
judiciaire à l'ensemble des adhérents de
la Fédération c'est le
second projet qui a été élu il faut dire
que à la Fédération française
d'équitation c'est réellement la base
qui vote puisqu'on a plus de 6000
votants qui sont les représentants des
clubs dirigeants professionnels ou
associatif et que euh ils ont le choix
de
pouvoir à la fois voter pour desquip
puisqu'il y a plusieurs collèges
différents et ils ont le choix de
pouvoir voter pour plusieurs collèges
différents en fonction de leur
aspiration le le le le le rôle du
candidat président c'est de monter une
équipe qui plaît le mieux possible C à
l'ensemble des des électeurs et puis de
faire passer l'ensemble de son équipe ça
aurait pu être le cas autrement il
aurait pu y avoir eu il aurait pu y
avoir des des des des collèges opposants
ça n'a pas été le cas ils n'ont pas été
élus donc ce si je comprends bien vous
êtes en majorité donc aucun débat
contradictoire comme je le disais le
débat contradictoire a lieu tous les ans
lors de l'assemblée générale lorsqu'on
présente nos actions qu'on présente nos
nos nos budgets et qu'on le soumet à
l'ensemble des adhérents de la
Fédération enfin c'est aussi une analyse
est-ce qu'on est dans une fédération
pour faire un combat politique permanent
ou est-ce qu'on est là pour faire
avancer les projets de la
Fédération l'opposition peut être
constructive quand on écoute le terrain
et qu'on travaille avec le terrain et
qu'on est adopté par le terrain la la la
la constructibilité du projet fédéral
elle est
permanente et les nouveaux statuts de la
FFE ont été adopté par l'Assemblée
générale comme vous disiez le 24
novembre 2022 pouvez-vous revenir sur
les changements apportés par rapport au
statut pr
précédent sur les sur les principaux
c'était pour prendre en compte les
évolutions de la loi donc la nouvelle
loi sur le sport de de mars 2022 euh un
point pour vous dire que la Fédération
était précurseur par rapport à ce que
vient de dire le président et le vote
des clubs notamment qui avait été retenu
après un vote soumis par
l'administration judiciaire en 2004
étant donné que aujourd'hui cette notion
de vote direct par les groupements
sportifs est une notion présente dans la
loi c'est le cas depuis 2000 au sein de
la Fédération française d'équitation
alors que il y a une seulement une dose
qui est injectée on va dire dans la
nouvel loi qui demande aux fédérations
donc de faire participer les clubs
sportifs seulement pour les élections
d'ailleurs pas pour l'adoption de
l'ensemble des résolutions en Assem
assemblé générale ordinaire donc ça ça a
été il n'y avait pas d'évolution pour la
Fédération sur ce point il y a eu des
évolutions en terme de parité parce que
la Fédération était jusque-l la
proportionnelle ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui 2 tiers des
administrateurs de la Fédération sont
des administratrice que nous étions à
proportionnel et nous sommes une
fédération majoritairement féminine par
les licenciés et par les dirigeantes
donc nous sommes passés d'une
proportionnelle à une parité donc 50 50
et également jusque là le la
représentativité des différents statuts
juridiques des groupements sportifs
était limité à 20 % dans les instances
des fédérations pour les groupements non
associatifs c'est-à-dire qu'on pouvait
avoir maximum 20 % de l'organe dirigeant
issu des groupements non associatifs et
80 % des groupements associatifs la
nouvelle loi sur le sport prévoit
également en ce point la
proportionnalité c'est-à-dire la prise
en compte de la physionomie de la
fédération et dans le cas de la
Fédération effectivement c'est plus de
de tiers des GR groupements qui sont de
nature non associative donc en tous les
cas il y aura une évolution sur la
répartition des sièges en ce
sens et la loi de démocratisation du
sport de mars 2022 prévoit également un
renouvellement des mandats limité à 3
c'est le cas également dans les statuts
de la fédération et c'est la loi donc il
n'y a pas à le prévoir au sein en plus
et puis pour finir sur le le scrutin il
y a également l'élection distincte de
représentants
desportifs de haut niveau et des
officiels de compétition pour notre part
ils étaient déjà intégrés dans les
instances fédérales étant donné que ce
qu'a indiqué le président tout à l'heure
sur le la une candidature par liste nous
avons un collège spécifique où il y a un
certain nombre de qualités requises avec
un médecin des officiels des
organisateurs des propriétaires de
chevaux de de sport et donc
effectivement on a pris en compte cette
demande et cette exigence de la loi de
tenir des scrutins séparés pour les
sportifs de haut niveau et pour les
officiels de compétition seront él par
leur père en dehors de l'élection
fédérale à l'issue de
celle-ci moi je vais revenir un tout
petit peu en arrière parce que tout à
l'heure je crois mais peut-être vous
allez nous le redire vous nous avez
affirmé que Monsieur kodal n'était pas
en contact avec des
mineurs qu' ne travaillait pas à
proximité de mineurs faction au niveau
de la Fédération oui il é embauché comme
chauffeur on vous l'a dit vous l'a
précisé tout à l'heure
et sur le circuit du Grand National
est-ce qu'il y avait des cavalières
mineurs ou pas le circuit du Grand
National est un lieu publique où tout le
monde peut il y a pas d'encadrement
sportif sur le Grand National c'est des
concurrents qui viennent avec leurs
chevaux et qui participent à la
compétition mais il y a pas
d'encadrement sportif ma question c'est
est-ce qu'il y a des mineurs des
cavaliers m il y a des mineurs partout
comme il y en a dans la rue oui mais
alors je vous pose une simple question
merci d'y répondre je vous pose une
question merci d'y répondre clairement
ma question était ce n'est pas ma
question néit je vais vous préciser la
réponse parce que je vois que vous vous
souhaitez aller au fond des choses
monsieur kodan n'avait aucune
responsabilité autorité sur aucun mineur
lors de ses déplacements et des ses
fonctions à la Fédération et donc est-ce
qu'il était présent ou pas sur ce site
il n'avait aucune fonction ni aucune
autorité sur aucun mineur lors de ses
déplacements pour la fédération en fait
vous ne répondz pas question était il
était il était il était présent s'il le
souhaitait on n'était pas on n'était pas
à bloquer il arrivait il déposait le
camion il montait son son son podium et
une fois que ça s'était terminé avant la
manifestation il était libre d'aller où
il voulait voilà oui mais moi ce que je
vous dis c'est donc le camion dont il
était en charge était un camion
d'accueil de la Fédération desitations
présent sur un circuit de compétition du
Grand National en l'occurrence où il y
avait des cavalières mineurs non pas en
général dans le Grand National non donc
vous me dites qu'il y avait pas de
mineur mais si moi je peux pas vous dire
qu'il y avait pas de lumière c'est un
lieu public ouvert à tout le monde mais
dans les candidats en tout cas dans les
concurrents du Grand National je je veux
dire que on doit compter les mineurs sur
le sur les doigts d'une m alors moi je
vous voyez je POS question ilce autorité
il avait aucune autorité avec je vous
pose les questions sans AER le ton ni
quoi que ce soit donc je vous
demanderais de faire j'habite à l'exérie
je vis à l'extérieur vous m'excuserez de
parler for et donc mes questions sont
simples je vous demande juste si au
moment où il était présent avec le
camion de de la Fédération d'équitation
s'il y avait des cavalières mineurs qui
pouvaient être présentes sur ce site oui
non c'est aussi simple que ça je je vous
ai répondu je vous ai dit que c'était un
lieu public où tout le monde pouvait
aller bien sûr des mineurs et qui
n'avait aucune fonction vis-à-vis des
mineurs et aucune autorité sur des
mineurs quel qu'il
soi et que la
restriction judiciaire était
l'encadrement d'activités sportive et
rien
d'autre quelle mesure de prévention des
conflits d'intérêts avez-vous mis en
œuvre au sein de la fédération s'il vous
plaît
il y en a de plusieurs il y en a
plusieurs natures déjà sur le on est
soumis bien sûr dans le casadre du code
du commerce à l'ensemble des dispositifs
liés aux conventions réglementées
c'est-à-dire les relations contractuel
qui pourrait y avoir entre des
administrateurs de la fédération et des
fournisseurs de la Fédération donc les
conventions réglementées chaque année
les administrateurs sont interrogés sur
les liens queeux même ou leur famillees
pourraient avoir avec la Fédération sont
soumises au commissaire au compte qui
rédige un rapport spécial comme le
prévoit la loi et donc rapport qui est
soumis à l'assemblée générale de la
Fédération euh chaque année euh il y a
également euh un certain nombre de de
sujets le le président remplit ses ses
obligations vis-à-vis de la chatvp euh
c'est également le cas depuis 2022 des
vice-présidents trésoriers et la
secrétaire générale de la Fédération
française d'équitation parallèlement la
le comité d'éthique et d'ontologie de la
Fédération a mis en place un dispositif
similaire pour les présidents des
comités régionaux
d'équitation voilà et et par ailleurs la
la Fédération travaille depuis 2022 sur
une cartographie des risques qui est en
cours de de finalisation et vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que comme d'autres
fédérations la Fédération Française
d'quitation a fait l'objet d'un contrôle
de l'Agence Française anti-orruption qui
n'est pas terminé qui est en cours et
dont on attend les
conclusions et pourriez-vous nous
communiquer le taux d'observance de la
surveillance médicale
réglementaire donc le oui le le le
fameux SMR ce qui s'adresse au sportifs
de haut niveau la Fédération française
d'équitation à
150 athlètes listé au 22 novembre donc
pour le millésime pour le millésime en
cours
[Musique]
euh et
donc sur les examens demandés dans le
casadre du suffit médical réglementé il
y a un é trocardiogramme pardon standard
de repos avec interprétation un bilan
examen médical locomoteur
cardiovasculaire pulmon ophtalmologique
un bilan diététique et alimentaire mode
de consommation habitude alimentaire un
bilan psychologique dépression trouble
anxieux violence trouble du sommeil un
usage de substances et en complément
traitement en cours
médicamentation usuelle existence d'une
autorisation à usage thérapeutique ou
non euh antécédents personnels médicaux
chirurgicaux soutendineux tabac dernière
vaccination et recherche d'un état de
surend de surentraînement pardon signes
fonctionnel et ou psychocomportementaux
et je vous demandais le le taux de de
surveillance le taux t de surveillance
qui doit
être sur
les on est à 100
% on arrive à 100 % sauf erreur cette
année en 2023 oui on a eu des scorses
moins bons certaines années mais nous
arrivons à si les chiffres que j'ai sous
les yeux sont bons nous arrivons à 2023
avec des chiffres variables entre les
différentes catégories et de SHN et les
différents mineurs majeurs et différents
une question notre collègue Claude
garouo oui parce que vous avez beau
parler fort Monsieur le Comte mais on
entend pas tout on comprend pas tout moi
je je je m'interroge quand même vous
avez vous aviez à titre privé pour votre
société une personne qui a été condamné
en
2013 pour agression sexuelle sur mineur
il est licencié et vous le recrutez au
sein de la fédération française
d'équitation alors même qu'il a pas de
mission auprès des jeunes mais vous
savez très bien que quelqu'un qui a été
au contact de jeune qui connaî qui
connaissent toutes les enfin qui le
connaissent très très bien vous preniez
un risque puisque il y a une récidive en
2017 et que il n'est licencié qu'en 2019
moi moi ce que je ne comprends pas parce
que vous prenez vous vous avez fait
prendre des risque à la Fédération c'est
pourquoi cette personne-l vous l'avez
recruté au sein de la fédération alors
que vous l' est licencié dans votre
entreprise madame d'abord il n'a pas été
licencié on s'est séparé après 15 ans
une quinzaine d'années voilà on s'est
séparé on n'est pas licencié donc pour
les raisons que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure ensuite la récidive comme vous
le dites elle a pas eu lieu après elle a
eu lieu avant son départ de mon
entreprise donc il y a pas eu de
récidive à la Fédération et il y a eu
aucun risque à la Fédération par rapport
à son comportement et je pense que en
plus de ça on a dû me demander mon avis
sur ce sur cet individu puisqu'il été
longtemps chez moi je n'ai eu qu'à me
féliciter des travaux et du travail que
j'ai eu avec lui et si on s'est séparé
c'est pour des raisons de personnees
intern à l'entreprise c'est une petite
entreprise où il y a quatre personnes
qui travaillent et il était pas possible
d'avoir un couple qui se déchire au vu
et au su de tout le monde alors vous
voyez là vous venez de répéter par
exemple ce que a dévoilé le le le
journaliste de Mia part en disant il a
été licencier et ce oui mais tout ça ça
fait partie de de de de de de
l'abondance de de de de de de de de de
des uns et des autres de de de de ce
qu'il souhaitent avoir pouvoir révéler
alors que y a il y a pas eu de
licenciement voilà tout
simplement et et et et et et tout ça je
comme je l'ai appris après pour le
moment de toute façon ça n'avait aucun
aucune incidence dessus puisque on se
séparait pour d'autres raisons et euh il
rentrait à la Fédération pour d'autres
raisons don donc si on a bien compris
tout ça c'est-à-dire que si aujourd'hui
vous êtes président de la Fédération
vous êtes au courant que un de vos
entraîneurs a un problème avec des
jeunes qu' est condamné pour autant vous
pourriez le recruter comme chauffeur
considérant que sa mission c'est d'être
offur et que il a aucun risque de
croiser des jeunes en compétition
d'équitation en fait vous avez pas tiré
les enseignements de ce que vous avez
vécu vous bah non mais je vous pose la
question et ben alors je vous repose une
question si aujourd'hui vous êtes au
fait que un entraîneur ou une
entraîneuse parce que ça peut être au
féminin ça arrive euh à donc est
condamné pour violence sexuel ou et bien
vous pourriez donc bien évidemment ne
pas le garder au contact des des jeunes
mais le recruter sur une autre mission
dans votre fédération c'est une question
que je vous
pose on a fait déjà souvent la réponse
on a eu des problèmes effectif avec des
entraîneurs la les mesures ont été
immédiates et radicales voilà mais il
fallait-il être au courant de ce qu'ils
ont fait là on l'était il y avait pas de
problème si je peux me permettre madame
la députée en toutous les cas en tant
que responsable des des ressources
humaines à la Fédération à ce jour
depuis la fin du 2 semestre 2023 et
c'est un peu dans le prolongement de la
mise en place du SI honorabilité pour
nos nos établissements équestres on
s'applique les mêmes règles étant donné
que nous demandons le bulletin numéro 3
du casier judiciaire pour l'ensemble des
salariés de la Fédération nous avons
commencé à le faire sur les contrats
saisonniers car nous avons beaucoup de
saisonniers pas sur des fonctions
d'encadrement sur des fonctions
d'entretien sur un site dont la
fédération est responsable avec des
mineurs l'été donc nous avons commencé à
le faire pour les manifestations du
mésim 2023 et nous l'avons généralisé à
tous les recrutements au sein de la
fédération depuis quel que soit le poste
y compris sur des fonctions sédentaires
de
bureau je voudrais rajouter ça a été une
bonne leçon quand même l'histoire CODAL
on l'a pris on l'a pris euh d'une façon
évidente mais ça a été une bonne leçon
si ça vous intéresse au moi il y a des
solutions dont on a besoin pour éviter
ce genre de situation parce que envoyer
un courrier dans la nature sans nom sans
destination c'est un sujet quand
même
monsieur Stéphane
bchou merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur
Général juste
pour pour bien
comprendre la chronologie de de de ce
qui s'est passé de son de ce dont on
vient de parler dans le cas présent donc
la personne en question je parle sous
votre contrôle elle est elle est
recrutée au sein de votre société
elle quitte la société selon ce que vous
venez de de nous indiquer euh vous avez
vous venez de préciser que il y avait eu
récidive avant qu'elle
intègre la Fédération Française est-ce
que j'ai bien compris donc vous avez
connaissance de sa condamnation
elle est en récidive et vous l'embauchez
à la à la Fédération Française je vais
je vais non non mais je je je je si vous
me le permettez je vais je vais terminer
moi ce que je veux comprendre c'est
quelles précautions sont
prises pour justement
éviter les dysfonctionnements qui sont
l'objet des travaux de cette
commission à vous
entendre vraisemblablement et je porte
pas d'accusation c'est juste un
constat la condamnation et la récidive
n'ont pas été suffisantes pour que vous
preniez à minima euh des mesures de de
précaution préalable étant
entendu et je je reprends vos
termes que la personne en question
n'était pas censé être au contact de
mineur le fait est ceci étant dit moi je
ne suis pas un spécialiste de
l'équitation que les compétitions dont
il a été question tout à l'heure vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que c'était un
lieu public
certes il y a quand même un risque fort
qu'il y ait justement des mineurs
donc c'est c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'arrive pas bien à à appréhender et à
comprendre et quelles ont été à ce
moment-là les mesures que vous avez
prise ou que vous n'avez pas prise vous
en tant que président de la fédération
et et vous monsieur en tant que
directeur général écoutez les choses
sont simples et je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure vous lisez les jugements vous
regardez les dates et vous comprendrez
tout tout
simplement en fait on vous demande de
répondre précisément à nos questions
donc en fait vous pouvez pas nous
renvoyer systématiquement au jugement on
vous demande de répondre donc il y a eu
une séparation entre vous il y a eu deux
condamnations vous nous dites que les
deux ont eu lieu avant qu'il intègre vos
effectifs à la Fédération d'équitation
on vous demande tout simplement de
répondre redonnez-nous la chronologie
des faits vous me posez plusieurs fois
la même question je vous a déjà répondu
donc pour moi sur ce sujet-là il est
clos j'ai plus rien à vous dire vous
lisez les jugements et vous serez au
courant alors les a les jugements on les
a Monsieur monsieur le monsieur le
Président j'ai peut-être vous rappelez
un peu les choses madame la Présidente
l'a dit tout à l'heure nous ne sommes
pas ici dans un tribunal ceci étant dit
dans son propos non non
mais si je peux si je peux terminer ma
phrase par contre nous sommes là pour
poser des questions encore une fois et
vous pour y répondre et je réitère et je
répète que vous ne pouvez pas en
permanence nous R
voyez ce que vous nous répondez depuis
le début de cette audition est-ce que
alors moi je vais vous poser la question
autrement est-ce que dans ce que je
viens de dire de ce que je viens de
rappeler il y a des choses
fausses mon audition depuis tout à
l'heure je vous ai expliqué que le
deuxième jugement qui est intervenu bien
après le premier sur des faits qui
avaient eu lieu avant le premier
jugement voilà je peux rien vous dire
d'autre lisez les jugements et vous vous
en aurez la confirmation le président
moi ma question elle est pas de savoir
si oui ou non je vais lire ou je dois
lire les jugements ma question porte sur
le fait que vous aviez conna
connaissance de fait de
condamnation de cette
personne et que malgré tout cette
personne a été recrutée au sein de la
Fédération française d'équitation et que
cela relève de mon point de vue d'un
dysfonctionnement et c'est l'objet des
travaux de cette commission vous me le
dites he si ce que je vous dis ne vous
intéresse pas vous me le dites et on
arrête tout de suite non vous me posez
10 fois la même question la même réponse
je vous ai dit que le deuxème
condamnation avait lieu sur des faits
qui étaient avant la première
condamnation et on l'a appris mais bien
après son embouche bien sûr bien après
son embouche vous regardez les dates des
jugements et vous vous en rendrez compte
tout de
suite et le premier jugement c'était
donc avant
l'embauche vous nous parlez du deuxième
jugement pour une affaire qui a eu lieu
avant c'est pour ça qu'on vous demande
de préciser la chronologie pas les
pièces en tête donc la prochaine fois si
vous m'invitez je viendrai avec les
jugements je vous lirai les jugements et
vous
comprendrez alors puisque ça semble
compliqué Monsieur le Délégué Général
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer les
propos de de monsieur le Président moi
je peux confirmer ce qui concerne la
fédération en tous les cas lors de
l'embuche de Monsieur CODAL la
Fédération n'avait pas en tant
qu'employeur n'avait pas connaissance du
jugement elle a eu connaissance de ce
jugement à postériori et elle a eu
connaissance du 2è jugement pour des
faits antérieurs au premer par rapport à
ce que après le départ de Monsieur CODAL
au moment où les faits ont été révélés
par l'enquête du journal donc il a
quitté l'entreprise en 2019 de mémoire
et c'est des faits qui ont été révélés
en 2020 euh voilà voilà en tout les cas
la connaissance du dossier et pour ma
part je ne pense pas avoir euh j'ai lu
le premier jugement sauf erreur je n'ai
jamais eu en main le deuxème jugement OK
et le premier jugement quand vous en
avez eu connaissance monsieur CODAL é
encore salarié de la fédération il me
semble que oui parce que je l'ai appris
par 100 ok donc vous venez de dire que
oui donc à ce moment-là quelles mesures
ont été prises par la Fédération lorsque
vous avez connaissance de ce premier
jugement est-ce que vous mettez fin à
son contrat est-ce qu'il y a une mise à
pied est-ce qu'il y a une mesure
conservatoire nous c'est ça qui nous
intéresse rien n'a été fait sur le plan
des ressources humaine et si j'ai
souvenir du jugement du dont on parle il
ne prévoyait aucune mesure expresse de
d'éloignement de mineur ou autrees voilà
n'avais pas d' informations assorties au
au jugement c'est la décision du
jugement mais la F AA pu prendre une
autre décision la Fédération n'a pas
pris d'autres mesures en ayant
connaissance de ce jugement et pourquoi
vous n'avez pris aucune
mesure par je ne sais pas je j'ai pas
d'explication à à vous
fournir on a fait juste d'appliquer la
loi juste fait que d'appliquer la loi la
loi nous nous imposait pas de prendre
une mesure conservatoire nouvelle à
quelqu'un qui avait été jugé et qui
avait purgé sa peine là vous nous
demandez quoi de faire un deuxème procès
après à Monsieur CODAL parce que on a
appris après coup un jugement sur des
fonctions qu' n'exerçait
plus en fait vous vous c'est pas des
fonctions qu' n'exerceit plus au moment
où vous avez connaissance du premier
jugement il est encore salarié de la
Fédération donc je je suis désolé à ce
moment-là vous auriez pu oui prendre une
décision de sanction je vous pose la
question sur pourquoi vous n'avez pas
pris cette décision la de ne pouvait
être qu'en conform avec le droit du
travail madame et le droit du travail ne
permettait pas de licencier quelqu'un
pour quelqu'un qui avait eu qui avait
qui avait été condamné qui avait jugé
purgé sa peine et qui n'exerçait pas les
fonctions qui étaient contreindiqué dans
son dans son
jugement juste une précision monsieur le
délégé général d'abord merci d'apporter
des réponse précise on s'y retrouve un
peu mieux simplement j'ai juste uneti
précision à vous demander vous avez
dit la Fédération
française n'en avait pas
connaissance ça veut dire
quoi pardon tout à l'heure il a été
évoquer les fonctions de Monsieur lecte
en tant qu'employeur de Monsieur CODAL
préalablement à son emboche à la
Fédération donc je distingue bien les
deux et donc la Fédération que je
représentais lorsque j'ai signé son
contrat de travail n'en avait pas
connaissance
donc pour bien comprendre vous faites le
distingo entre la Fédération française
d'équitation et le président de la
Fédération française d'équitation c'est
ce qu'il faut comprendre ou
pas bon on va pas y passer l'après-midi
mais pour bien comprendre je
m'étonne
que vous n'absorbiez pas les deux
c'estàdire que je crois mais peut-être
peut-être me trompe je crois je crois
comprendre que lorsque vous dites le la
Fédération vous n'y incluez pas
nécessairement le président est-ce que
je comprends bien ou
pas le fait président m'a donné
délégation pour gérer l'ensemble des
ressources humaines et n'intervient pas
dans les processus de recrutement donc
depuis 2013 depuis le 1er septembre 2013
si c'est votre question donc moi je peux
vous parler de ce qui se passe à la
Fédération je ne peux pas vous parler de
ce qui se passe dans les entreprises
tiersce quel que soient d'ailleurs les
ses entreprises même si les individus
sont un jour passés par la Fédération
alors c'est pas tout à fait la question
c'est pas la question donc la question
c'est on vous a demandé ce qui était au
courant grosso modo vous nous indiquez
que la Fédération d'équitation n'était
pas n'était pas informée au moment où
vous l'avez recruté et en faisant cela
vous faites le distingo entre la
Fédération en tant que telle et donc
monsieur le compte c'est la question
pardon je fais aucun distingo je n'étais
pas informé point et voilà le distingo
se fait sur la nature de l'employeur et
pas sur autre ch vous là vous dites je
n'étais pas informé donc ça veut dire
que d'autes personnes l'était non je
n'étais pas informé c'est moi qui signe
le contrat de travail donc en tant
qu'employeur représentant légal de
l'entreprise FFE je n'étais pas informé
au nom de la fédération de ce jugement
et de cette condamnation et est-ce queà
votre connaissance d'autres personnes
étaient informées de ce jugement ou de
cette condamnation au moment où vous
l'avez
recruté à en croire les déclarations de
de la minist Desport quelques années
plus tard il faut croire que oui mais en
tous les cas courrier auquel nous
n'avons pas eu de réponse d'ailleurs 4
juin 10 juin et 22 juin où nous avons
demandé à la ministre des Sports de nous
fournir les pièces euh relatives à la
manière dont euh la fédération ou
Monsieur le Comte auraient pu être
informé j'ai les courriers ici he
courrier du 10 juin du 12 juin et du 22
juin euh en tous les cas on n'a jamais
eu de réponse à ces courriers sur la
manière dont on aurait pu être informé
et donc nous ne l'étions pas et nous
l'avons été bien après comme je vou l'ai
indiqué précédemment d'cord donc je
redis hein vous êtes sous cerment tous
les deux donc je le reprécise et euh
j'entends votre réponse donc vous
confirmez selon vous personne d'autre à
la Fédération n'était informé au moment
de son recrutement vous pouvez
confirmer je peux parler pour moi je
peux pas parler pour pour d'autres
personnes je si c'est la
question ma question c'est est-ce que
selon vous personne d'autre que vous
n'était informé au moment de son
recrutement de la
condamnation la direction départementale
est informée puisque c'est eux qui
envoyé le
courrier je parle de la Fédération je
vais vous demander de répondre s'il vous
plaît je vous reformule ma réponse je ne
peux répondre que pour moi et je n'ai
pas d'information sur d'autres personnes
qui auraient été informé
oui alors désolé déjà d'être arrivé à
retard et peut-être que ce que je vais
vous
dire peut être redondant pour vous j'en
suis vraiment désolé mais ça me permet
finalement d'arriver avec un œil un
petit peu un peu neuf là sur les débats
qui viennent de de se dérouler si je
comprends bien donc la personne donc qui
pose aujourd'hui difficulté ou qui a
posé difficulté pardon c'était donc
votre ancien salarié dans une structure
privée et qui a été ensuite recruté donc
au sein de la fédération dont vous étiez
le président tout à l'heure vous avez
dit mais le représentant légal de la FD
c'est moi et moi j'étais pas au courant
c'est ce que vous avez dit Monsieur le
Directeur mais le représentant légal de
la FD c'est le
président par sur le plan des des
ressources humaines où j'ai reçu
délégation pour gérer l'ensemble des
ressources humaines pas représentation
légale au sens strict du
terme effectivement de responsabilité
notamment pour la la gestion des
ressources humaines mais n'empêche que
le représentant légal de la FD c'est
monsieur le Président donc monsieur le
président
qui a eu à connaître de la situation de
son ancien salarié ne peut pas ignorer
la situation du nouveau recruté au sein
de la fédération bon il n'empêche que
c'est vous effectivement donc qui qui
formaliser donc les l'embauche de cette
personne et donc vous n'êtes pas au
courant à ce moment-là c'est bien ça et
quand vous êtes mis au courant de la
situation de cette personne que vous
avez
recruté
donc vous allez si je comprends bien
regarder son jugement les faits pour
lesquels il a été
condamné la
condamnation c'est ça et et et vous
parce que là quand vous apprenez qu'il a
été condamné l'idée enfin il me semble
que c'est de dire ben pourquoi il a été
condamné et quels sont les éléments de
cette condamnation et est-ce que
notamment les éléments de cette
condamnation rendent incompatible le
maintien dans son contrat de travail au
sein de la fédération française
d'équitation c'est comme ça que vous
avez
raisonné c'est comme ça que j'ai
raisonné je ne sais pas le dater savoir
quand est-ce que j'ai été informé je
vous l'ai dit tout que j'avais été
informé par par son épouse qui était
également sal de la fédération qui qui a
dû rejoindre les effectifs de la
Fédération 8 9 mois après
lui-même et c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris et voilà et en tous les cas il
m'est pas apparu par rapport à
l'interdiction d'exercer une activité
avec les mineurs que cela pouvait être
incomatible avec un poste d'agent
d'entretien chauffeur je l'ai dit
également tout à
l'heure permettez à la Fédération on a
on a recruté d'autres personnes plus
plus à risque que Monsieur Godal
puisqu'on a recruté des prisonniers qui
sortaient de prison et qui avaient des
fonctions d'entretien de de jardiners de
maçons et cetera donc on a aussi une
vocation sociale c'est de remettre les
gens sur les
rails mais moi je al moi je vous mets
tout à fait à l'aise je considère que
des personnes qui ont été condamnées qui
ont purgé leur peine euh ont le droit de
revenir dans le circuit mais il peut y
avoir un jugement qui pour le coup leur
interdit d'être en contact avec
notamment des mineurs et cetera donc
c'est ça me paraît important que vous
employeurs au moment où vous êtes au
courant d'une condamnation préalable à
son embauche vous puissiez véritablement
vérifier s'il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité entre les nouvelles
fonctions et le contact qu'il peut avoir
avec des mineur et les termes de de
cette condamnation c'est juste moi la la
question que que je vous pose et et
comment vous vous en êtes assuré quels
étaient les termes de cette condamnation
et est-ce que véritablement il y avait
une
étanchéité infranchissable donc entre
ses fonctions et les termes de cette
condamnation
voilà je peux aller plus loin il a été
condamné à 15 jours avec
surcis et
interdiction et retraite son diplôme
d'AD de d'entraîneur sportif d'éducateur
sportif voilà donc ça voulait dire qu'il
ne pouvait plus de faire l'encadrement
sportif et rien
d'autre est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quoi il rentrera pas ah donc
on vous a posé la question est-ce que
aujourd'hui vous vous suivriez le même
raisonnement ou est-ce que ce serait
différent mais a priori vous avez déjà
répondu alors peut-être monsieur le
compte vous pouvez nous indiquer en
quelle année vous avez été euh
euh entendu ou auditionné dans le cadre
de la procédure judiciaire je je me
souviens plus honnêtement je me souviens
plus avant son recrutement non après
bien après bien après mais je me
souviens plus quand je me souviens plus
les dates mais si vous avez l'audition
vous c'est marqué dessus mais je je me
souviens plus et même question pour
vous enfin vous savez en quelle année il
y a eu cette audition ah pas du tout
j'ai pas de pas d'information sur cette
audition j'étais en toutous les cas pas
été
auditionné alors moi ce que je voilà
selon nos informations vous vous auriez
été auditionné en
2017 sur dans le cadre de la procédure
judiciaire ouverte à l'encontre de
Monsieur CODAL donc dans ce cadre là
vous avez
mais vous étiez donc informé en 2017
mais non mais attendez là on parle de on
parle d'un jugement qui a eu lieu en
2013 et d'un recrutement qui a eu lieu
en 2014 c'est ça donc en 2017 bien sûr
bien
après mais oui mais une audition madame
une audition
par par la police c'est pas une
condamnation hein non mais en fait c'est
pas la question moi je vous demande pas
si l'histoire sa condamnation la
question c'est est-ce que vous étiez
informé vous êtes auditionné en 2017
dans le cadre de la procédure judiciaire
donc forcément à un moment ou un autre
vous avez été informé puisque vous êtes
auditionné dans le cadre de la procédure
judiciaire en 2017 donc la question
c'est voilà c'est alors une nouvelle
fois je vais vous répondre parce que là
ça vous me réveillez quelques
souvenirs le le la condamnation je l'ai
pas appris au commissariat de police
hein et au commissariat de police on m'a
additionné sans me dire queles étaient
les raisons des faits de l'audition on
m'a auditionné sur monsieur CODAL sans
me dire les raisons voilà on m' on m'a
on m'a questionné re questionestionner
j'ai j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire
voilà donc c'est pas la peine de de
mélanger les deux ça n'a rien à voir en
aucun cas au commissariat on m'a dit il
a été condamné il a fait c il a fait ça
et cetera en aucun cas on m' on m'a posé
des questions point la ligne mais je
suis étonné quand même que on passe
depuis 1 heure son temps sur une
affaire sur une faire de voleur de
pommes je suis pas certaine que je
parlerai de voleur de pomme pour au vu
des accusations et au vu de et des
condamnations mais chacun est libre de
des mots et de son interprétation de
cette affaire et je pense que pour le
coup c'est au parlementaires de décider
sur quel sujet ils veulent appuyer en
particulier sur quel sujet on souhaite
creuser pour justement déterminer les
dysfonctionnements et apporter des
solutions donc ça fait effectivement 1
heure qu'on essaie de comprendre à quel
moment vous êtes informé pourquoi la
fédération ne prend pas de mesure au
moment où vous êtes informé d'ailleurs
ça serait intéressant de savoir au
moment où vous vous séparez de ce
monsieur quel est le motif de la
séparation enfin qu'est-ce qui a est
écrit sur son courrier de licenciement
s'il a été licencié ce monsieur avec son
épouse ont voulu s'installer et
reprendre une écurie donc ils sont
partis pour reprendre une écurie ce
qu'ils ont fait voilà tout simplement
donc vous êtes informé de la
condamnation c'est ce que nous a dit dit
Monsieur Bou boui pardon et donc vous
n'inscrivez rien dans le motif de son de
son licenciement ou de sa séparation il
y a rien qui a é inscrit il part comme
ça mais madame il a été jugé il a été
condamné il a purger sa peine vous
voulez quoi d'autre dites-nous ce qu'il
faut faire de plus alors
alors tu vas-y non mais franchement moi
je encore une fois he moi je je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je qu'on peut
recruter quelqu'un qui a été condamné
par le passé
Mo
mais vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi il a
été condamné ce
monsieur donner les essayer de de nous
qualifier à postérior les pour lesquel
éé
condamné alors le micro vous l'avez
pas
sous ou sous réserve de lire le jugement
avec exactitude il a condamné été
condamné à 15 jours avec surci pour
avoir eu des relations
consenti avec une mineure de plus de 15
ans pleainte déposé par les parents ce
que je comprends tout à fait
voilà et et la seconde fois jeaurais pas
vous dire de la même façon que le
premier jugement mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est du même même ressort et je suis
d'accord bien sûr je partage que j'urais
su les fait au moment où il était salari
chez moi j'aurais réglé les problèmes
immédiatement bien
sûr les faits pour lesquels il a été
condamné de il voleur de pommees quand
même en fait c'est pas c'est pas
admissible que vous puissiez dire dans
le casre d'une commission d'enquête qui
traite quand même le sujet qui dépasse
le casre de votre fédération mais le
sujet général en général des des
violences sexuel et et sexiste en nous
disant mais cette personne là en je pas
on va pas on va pas épiloguer c'est un
voleur de pomme quoi
enfin encore une fois en fait je je
crois qu'il y a un décalage entre
l'appréciation qui est la votre
aujourd'hui encore de ces faits malgré
le fait que vous êtes amené à en parler
devant une commission d'enquête qui
traite spécialement de ce sujet et et
est ce que vous nous dites quoi en fait
c'est pourene les en conscience quand
Mme c'est bien pour ça que je suis
étonné parce queon a autrement plus
grave la fédération dont on naborde
absolument pas le sujet aujourd'hui mais
non je répond aux questions heut oui
alors avant de passer vous inquiétez pas
on passera aux autres sujets
euh donc moi j'aimerais quand même
revenir sur cette audition en 2017 où
vous nous indiquez que vous n'étiez pas
informé donc la police vous interroge
sur ce monsieur sans vous donner les
causes et les raisons pour lesquelles il
vous interroge concernant cette personne
et donc de 2017 à
2019 qu'est-ce qui se passe c'està
direire que vous ne vous interrogez pas
vous lui posez pas de question vous
n'interrogez pas son contrat de travail
chez vous rien il ne se passe rien c'est
là c'est une question que je vous pose
mais la question je vous ai déjà répondu
madame vous me posez une question d'une
fois de plus pour moi quelqu'un qui a
été dénoncé jugé condamné et qui a purgé
sa peine je ne peux pas je n'ai pas
intervenir davantage non mais au moment
où vous êtes interrogé en 2017 il avait
pas pu si cétait terminé bien
sûr bien sûr que c'était terminé non ou
alors attends c'était une
enquête
vous pouvez confirmer s'il vous plaît
monsieur Bou non alors Monsieur Bou s'il
vous plaît est quelle est votre question
madame je vousose la même question en
2017 lorsque Monsieur le Président est
auditionné dans le cadre de cette
enquête qu'est-ce qui se passe au niveau
de la Fédération entre 2017 et
2019 je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il il ne
s'est rien passé je sais pas si en 2017
que la Fédération a été informée en tout
les cas c'est en 2017 que monsieur le
Président est auditionné par le
Commissariat
visiblement j'ai pas j'ai pas la date de
cette audition en toutous les cas je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure qu' ne s'était
rien passé que ça ne se reproduirait pas
aujourd'hui mais qu' ne s'était rien
passé lorsque nous avions appris la
condamnation de Monsieur CODAL pour les
fait que vous venez
d'évoquer bon bien je vous propose qu'on
passe aux autres affaires puisque
visiblement vous avez d'autres affaires
à nous exposer
donc vous écoute peut-être monsieur boui
si vous voulez commencer sur les autres
cas visiblement qui sont autrement plus
problématique c'est je crois
l'expression que vous avez
utilisé ENL tout à
l'URE ok on peutre passer sur la
question disciplinaire puisque là en
l'occurrence sur cette affaire là il y a
pas eu de déclenchement de commission
disciplinaire comment ça fonctionne
maintenant sur cette action
disciplinaire au sein de votre
fédération
peut-être est-ce que peut-être pouvez
nous indiquer le périmètre de votre
action disciplinaire dans le
règlement le périmètre des actions
disciplinaires jusqu'en septembre 2022
ne concernait que les activités
organisées par la Fédération française
d'équitation donc depuis le règlement
général disciplinaire de la Fédération a
été modifié et dans le cadre des
violences sexuelles des VSS concerne
l'ensemble des faits dont à connaître la
Fédération et pas seulement comme ça
peut être le cas pour d'autres dossiers
que sur le périmètre des activités
organisées par la Fédération
c'est-à-dire principalement les
activités de de compétition étant donné
que contrairement à d'autres fédérations
l'ensemble de l'encadrement est un
encadrement professionnel et qu'on n'est
pas obligé d'être licencié ni même que
le club soit adhérent pour exercer les
métiers d'éducateurs sportifs donc c'est
pour ça que le périmè initial qui était
le périmètre historique du règlement
général et disciplinaire de la
Fédération était restreint aux activités
donc organisées par la Fédération pour
ne pas s'imisser dans les activités
commerciales que pouvaient avoir les
adhérents de la Fédération donc les
choses ont évolué en en septembre 2022
pour ce point-là en
particulier juste sur sur le périmètre
justement de de ce règlement est-ce
qu'il avait fait l'objet de remarques
euh par le ministère des Sports
il a fait des l'objet de remarque de la
part de l'Inspection Générale qui l'a
mentionné dans dans son rapport et je
tiens à souligner comme nous l'avons
fait auprès de l'inspection que ce
règlement général disciplinaire avait
été approuvé par les services du
ministère des sports comme l'ensemble
des textes
fédéraux en quelle année il a été
validé le précédent ou
le je peux j'ai documents je peux
chercher un peu et vous donner la date
si vous
voulez
alors en attendant peut-être une
question sur les cartes
professionnelleséducateur est-ce que
vous procédez à leur vérification à
l'embauche pour ce qui concerne le
personnel de la Fédération bien sûr mais
pas pour pas pour les personnel des
adhérents groupement sportifs de la
Fédération c'est à l'employeur de le
faire pour pardon pourp 2017 pour
répondre à votre question la précédente
version du règlement général
disciplinaire qui avait fait l'objet
d'une approbation par les services de la
Direction des
Sports je venir sur la carte
professionnelle parce que c'est un vrai
sujet pour nous aider à détecter tous
les comportements qui doivent être
suivis de de de mesures de conservation
et le le le le le le le fonctionnement
de des cartes professionnelles le
fichier national qui pourrait en avoir
lieu et la capacité à la Fédération de
pouvoir le consulter nous permettrait
effectivement de travailler d'une façon
efficace
êtes-vous satisfait de votre partenariat
avec colos au pied d'argile et comment
se décline-t-il
concrètement il a essentiellement été
concentré sur des actions de de
formation et de sensibilisation du on va
dire de l'encadrement fédéral des élus
du comité fédéral des présidents de
comités régionaux de des salariés de la
Fédération euh et également de
l'ensemble des membres des commissions
juridiques et disciplinaires et comités
d'éthique de la Fédération sur ces
sujets-là donc ça c'est l'action
nationale dont dont j'ai le bilan et
également il y a ensuite des
partenariats locaux ù colosse au-delà de
la convention liée qui le lie à la
Fédération à des une intervention en
région à travers l'action bien sûr des
dragès et des comités régionaux
d'équitation où il y a des interventions
spécifiques et nous avons également fait
des intervention spécifique sur des
publics mineurs à l'occasion de grands
rassemblements au parc et caisse fédéral
ou à l'occasion de championnats réservés
aux enseignants qui sont également une
cible à sensibiliser et à
former et votre partenariat il se
décline sur combien d'heures et pour
quel
montant nous avons signé une convention
en 2021 qui a été recom ite en 2022 pour
3 ans il y avait des sensibilisations en
visionférence des sensibilisations en
présentiel des formations présentiel
donc il y a eu un certain nombre de de
coûts sur les sur les parties
matérielles notamment qui s'est élevé à
5000 voilà un peu plus de 5400 € sans
compter le travail de d'envoi de
dossiers tantis que nous avons adressé à
l'ensemble des groupements sportifs un
dossier complet comme le laffé colos au
piedargile avec d'autres fédérations
sport sportive avec un l'ensemble de kit
de d'information de formation à
l'ensemble des dirigeants qui étai pris
en et l'impression et la diffusion qui a
été prise en charge par la fédération
qui n'est pas dans dans ce budget
là combien d'articles 40 avez-vous
fait j'ai eu à faire un signalement au
procureur de la République cet été qui
n'a pas été suivi des faits car le
procureur m'a répondu que étant doné
qu'il n'y avait pas de plainte des
parents euh il n'y averait pas de suite
au dossier et donc le dossier est en
cours d'instruction par la commission
disciplinaire faisait partie des
dossiers renvoyés en début d'année 2024
c'est la seule action en direct que j'ai
eu à faire auprès du
Procureur et ce sont des faits de quelle
nature relation sexuelle entre un
officiel de compétition et un bénévole
sur une manifestation sportive avec plus
de 5 ans d'écart d'âge entre entre la
mineur et l'official de
compétition j'ai son identité que je
pourrais vous communiquer issu de
l'audition si vous le souhaitez donc
mineur bénévole mineur de quel âge je
n'ai pas l'âge
exact 16 ans d'après ma collaboratrice
en fond de salle qui était pas vraiment
une bénévole qui était une élève dans un
chantier école avec une maison familiale
voilà sur une manifestation organisée
par la Fédération donc avec une
convention de chanti qui école pour des
jeunes qui préparent des diplômes li au
cheval et l'officiel de compétition donc
qui était un arbitre de cette même
compétition et donc dès lors que nous
avons appris cela par l'encadrement de
la jeune de la jeune fille nous avons
écrit au procureur de la République
début juillet sauf erreur nous nous
sommes émus par écrit de la réponse qu'
pouvait nous apporter il nous a il a
fini par nous expliquer que c'était lui
le procureur qui décidait d' Tacte en
tous les cas la commission disciplinaire
de la Fédération a été saisie par le
président à la suite de cette réponse et
le juge à quel âge
j'ai pas son âge exact en toutous les
cas il y avait plus de 5 ans de plus de
5 ans d'écart je pense qu'il a au moins
plus de 30 ans en toutous les cas un âge
un écart d'age
suffisant et sur les autres cas moi
j'aimerais revenir tout à l'heure vous
nous avez donné des chiffres alors j'ai
plus tout en tête mais je crois 2018 il
y a eu un cas
20215 c'était sur les sanctions
disciplinaires ou c'est sur les
signalements c'était sur des sanctions
disciplinaires donc sur des décisions de
la commission juridique disciplinaire de
la Fédération alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner le nombre de
signalements notamment sur la question
des de des VSS et euh peut-être pourquoi
vous n'avez eu vous n'avez fait qu'un
article 40 pourquoi est-ce qu'il y en
a'a pas eu plus sur les autres cas
notamment de de
VSS la plupart des cas faisaient déjà
l'objet de poursuite judiciaire
lorsqu'on en a été informé ou lorsqu'on
a recroisé les informations avec la
sélule signalement du ministère des
Sports et il y a euh 8 cas euh off
erreur qui n'ont pas fait l'objet de
signalement et qui n'ont pas fait
l'objet de procédure judiciaire de cas
avec des faits antérieur à
2000 donc dont un de daté de
1971 de signalements anonymes
euh un fait relatant des pardon un
signalement relatant des faits euh non
pénalisables qui était des propos voilà
des propos déplacés mais non
pénalisables et euh deux pour lequel
nous sommes en attente d'information
complémentaires euh plus ceux qui font
l'objet d'une commission disciplinaire
qui est en cours alors juste sur les
propos qui sont non pénalisables qui
décide que c'est non pénalisable bon on
a une référente en charge de ce dossier
qui est juriste de formation et voilà
c'est l'interprétation éventuellement
elle le partage avec d'autres collègues
juristes ouou les compétences
judiciaires en la matière et quand c'est
comme ça est-ce que vous faites un
aller-retour avec euh la direction des
sports euh pour pour savoir justement
peut-être les décisions à prendre s'il
faut faire par un article 40 l'ensemble
des signalements reçus la Fédération
font l'objet d'un signalement au
ministère des Sports
immédiatement et donc soit la le
ministère des Sports a déjà connaissance
du signalement soit il n a pas
connaissance ou il en a connaissance
parfois à postériori en tous les cas
l'ensemble la fédération ne conserve
aucun signalement quel que soit la suite
qu'elle y donne commission disciplinaire
ou
pas
peut-être juste sur l'affaire que vous
avez évoqué avec le l'article 40 que
vous avez fait euh cette personne sur
laquelle vous avez fait un article 40 où
est-ce qu'il est aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il il exerce toujours c'est un
officiel de compétition nous avons
immédiatement suspendu ses fonctions
d'oficiel de compétition c'est les
seules activités dans tous les cas pour
lequel la Fédération a une maîtrise
aujourd'hui et on attend de la décision
de la commission juridique et
disciplinaire qui devrait se tenir en
début d'année et donc en attendant il
fait quoi il est présent pas présent
mais n nous on a aucune capacité à
prendre des mesures de quelconque
d'éloignement sans jugement t les cas ce
qu'on peut s'assurer c'est qu'il ne soit
pas officiel de compétition sur une
compétition organisée par la Fédération
donc ces fonctions d'officiel ont été
suspendu quand je dis officiel c'est
juge juge arbitre c'est la même
chose
euh il est licencié
oui il est licencié de la fédération
mais ça licence ne lui donne aucun droit
d'activité en dehors de pratiquer son
sport y compris et d'être assuré en tous
les cas le retrait de la licence ne ne
changerait rien à sa capacité à se
déplacer ou à participer à des activités
non fédérales oui mais la question du
coup c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas
une suspension par exemple ou une mesure
disciplinaire de suspension de sa
licence en attendant justement
la suite d'une éventuelle
procédure c'est pas aujourd'hui en
toutous les cas le le cas il est arrivé
que la commission juridique
disciplinaire prenne des mesures
conservatoires en attendant son audience
en tous les cas dans le cas de cette
officiel de compétition là encore une
fois la suspension de sa licence
n'aurait aucune incidence sur son
activité étant donné qu'il n'est pas
éducateur sportif il n'y a pas
d'éducateur bénévooles qui nécessit une
licence à la Fédération la seule
fonction fédérale qu'il a c'est celle de
juger arbitre qui est pendu donc il ne
peut pas exercer et par ailleurs
l'assurance couvre également une
assurance pour sa pratique et on ne peut
pas suspendre une assurance de cette
manière là sans décision
disciplinaire et vous conviendrez quand
même quand on a une licence on est plus
à même d'aller de circuler sur un centre
écastre plus que qu'une personne sans
licence vous me permettez il y a un peu
près 2 millions de cavaliers
occasionnels ou permanents dans notre
pays il y en a 700000 de licenciés il y
en a 1200000 au moins qui pratiquent
l'équitation qui pratiquent les établ
est qui sont pas tous affiliés à la
Fédération d'ailleurs qui qui vont et
qui viennent dans le milieu équest bien
sûr il est quand même plus usuel de se
déplacer avec une licence dans un centre
équestre pour pratiquer en de cas son
sport la licence en équitation à la deux
fonctions la première fonction c'est
pour les cavaliers qui souhaitent faire
de la compétition là ils sont dans un
cadre qui est plutôt bien organisé et
suivi la deuxième fonction c'est d'avoir
une couverture d'assurance voilà et et
en général ça ça se limite la prise
deassissance se limite à cette
raison-là peut-être juste sur le nombre
de signalements parce que vous vous
m'avez pas donné les chiffres euh sur
ces dernières années vous êtes à
peut-être combien de
signalements nous avons effectué euh
nous avons reçu 803 signalements euh en
sachant que certains signalements
concernent plusieurs euh alors juste je
vais vous demander de préciser les
années peut-être parce que 83
signalements c'est sur plusieurs années
alors 83 signalements depuis
2020 certains signalements peuvent
concerner la même personne nous en avons
reçu 29 en 2020 18 en 2021 19 en 2022 et
17 en 2023 et avant
2020 avant 2020 il n'y avait pas de
procédure de signalement à proprement
parler la Fédération a mis en place une
procédure de signalement avant même
d'ailleurs signal sport qui est la
procédure du ministère des Sports
d'ailleurs le la plateforme de
signalement de la Fédération française
d'équitation a été salué elle a été mise
en place lorsque nous en avons
malheureusement eu besoin en février
2020 avec un formulaire qui a été
d'ailleurs recopié par le ministère des
Sports pour ensuite être décliné sur
signal sport et avant nous avions eu à
connaître de cas qui ont été traités
notamment en commission disciplinaire ou
avec des suspensions de fonction ou euh
ou autre lié à à la chose notamment en
2018 avec un cadre un cadre d'État
stagiaire combien de licenciés à la
Fédération
675000 pour le mésim
2023 une une question de Claudia rouo
euh oui ce qui était intéressant c'est
vos propos là sur la carte de
professionnel c'est-à-dire que la
difficulté de la Fédération c'est que
vous avez des centres équestes qui sont
privés c'est ça avec quelquefois même
des des cavaliers qui ne sont pas
licenciés donc mais là vous n'êtes en
rien concerné s'il y a quelque chose ou
malgré tout vous êtes alerté ça c'est ma
ma première question et s'agissant de ce
juge arbitre là qui a eu des relations
sexuelles avec une jeune fille est-ce
que vous avez prévenu quand même le
centrequeste à laquelle il est affilié
de ce qui s'est
passé alors le le centre équestre n'est
pas un centre équestre de rattachement
on n'est pas c'est peut-être une
particularité par d'autres sport où on
est on a sa licence dans le club où en
pratique ou dans le club où on encadre
les centres équa sont des émetteurs de
licence et il est fréquent notamment sur
les jug arbitre que le juge arbitre
n'est jamais de relation avec son centre
équestre et souvent le centre équestre
ou l'association de proximité où il
prend sa licence pour exercer ses
fonctions de juger arbitre donc il n'y a
pas eu de d'information si c'est votre
question aux dirigeants de l'association
qui qui lui a délivré sa licence et
voilà et en cas en attendant le le
jugement de la commission disciplinaire
oui mais enfin là je je comprends pas
pourquoi parce que il est de toute façon
il est bien licencié quelque part et
donc là il peut être à contact aussi
dans son centre écaisse dans l'hypothèse
s'il l'est pas c'est pas le cas mais
avec des jeunes filles et tout et donc
là vous pourriez quand même avoir des
mesures de protection en avertissant
quand même le le centre pourquoi vous
enfin pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas fait
si c'est s'il était affilié nulle part
comme certains jures Arbites je bien le
croire mais s'il est affilié dans un
centre équestre ou dans un club ça
serait quand même intéressant d'informer
le club de ce qui s'est
passé je
peux madame la Présidente ouais oui je
je pardon dans le prolongement de de ce
que vient de dire ma ma collègue moi je
voulais revenir sur la sur la question
de la licence alors j'entends
parfaitement monsieur le président les
chiffres que vous nous avancez 2
millions de pratiquants 700000
licenciers 1200000 cavaliers
qui qui exer enfin qui euh pratique
pardon sans sans licence non simplement
euh vu de l'extérieur moi je m'interroge
sur sur le message euh et sur l'image de
la
Fédération vous avez là quelqu'un qui
est
condamné euh et et la et la licence est
maintenue et et ce que j'aimerais
comprendre c'est les raisons qui euh
vous pousse à maintenir cette licence
alors
j'entends les
raisons j'entends les raisons juridiques
euh mais pour reprendre l'expression de
ma collègue en terme de mesures de
protection en terme de message envoyés à
l'extérieur vous avez quand même une une
obligation
de sécurité de vos
pratiquants le fait que cette personne
continue à à avoir sa sa licence
qu'est-ce qui vous empêche au fond de
dire nonobstant le fait qu'il fallait
peut-être l'inscrire dans les statuts
j'en sais rien bah dans un cas comme
celui-là la Fédération prend la décision
de retirer la
licence qu'est-ce qui vous empêche de le
faire est-ce qu'il y a d'ailleurs
quelque chose qui vous empêche de le
faire quel est le le fondement juridique
de ce retrait de licence on a déjà eu
des condamnations sur des cavaliers
professionnels à qui on a retiré la
licence qui sont allés au tribunal on a
perdu à tous les
coups dès lors qu'ils avaient purgé leur
peine dès lors qu'il répondaient au
critèr d'une prise de licence on ne
pouvait pas les interdir de faire leur
métier donc on veut bien nous retirer
des licences mais avec un vrai fondement
juridique
monsieur BCK est-ce que vous pourvez
nous remettre s'il vous plaît le
courrier d'échange entre la FFE et le
procureur pour cette affaire citée oui
je peux le faire je c'est un échange de
mail que de courrier puis de mail que
j'ai ici que je pourrais même vous
remettre à l'issue de l'audition si vous
le souhaitez très bien
merci oui bien sûr juste une précision
monsieur le Président j'entends la
réponse que vous nous que vous me
faites vous dites les cavaliers font un
recours s'il y a une s'il y a une
condamnation avec
euh ferme avec une une mesure
d'éloignement je je la justice revient
sur sur son précédent
jugement il a une condamnation on
applique la condamnation il y a pas de
problème mais la la condamnation est
rarement étendue sur
l'après enfin une fois que la peine est
purgé donc à à la à la sa limite dans le
temps sauf parce que là on est on est
dans deux cas de figures différents tout
à l'heure on parler d'un cas de figure
où il y avait un retrait de du du
diplôme d'encadrement donc tant que le
diplôme est retiré a pas de discussion à
avoir quel que soit le l'endroit mais là
on parle de d'e d'une pratique équestre
s'il y a une condamnation euh enfin sous
sous réserve de de de des juristes qui
suivent ces dossiers là on na jamais vu
un jugement qui qui interdisait au
cavalier de prétendre à prendre sa
licence non non mais dans dans le cas
dans le cas dont vous faisiez état
Monsieur le Délégué Général là
euh donc vous nous confirmez que cette
personne est toujours détentrice
détenteur d'une d'une licence
mais cas que celui qui a fait l'objet
d'inellement au procureur effectivement
nous avons retiré immédiatement ces
fonctions d'officiel de compétition qui
sont à notre connaissance la situation
sur lequelle il peut être amené à
exercer et ce que lui permet sa licence
donc nous avons suspendu ces fonctions
d'officiel de compétition et le dossier
est en cours d'instruction par la
commission disciplinaire qui donc il n'y
a pas de jugement euh en tous les cas le
le jugement fédéral si on peut l'appeler
ainsi interviendra normalement en début
d'année vous me permettez une anecdote
ancienne mais qui montre bien la limite
de nos de nos
pouvoirs qui qui qui est bien antécédent
à tout ça un centrecasse important à un
instructeur d'environ 45 ans qui a des
des relations enfin des des actes
délictueux vis-à-vis des
mineurs l'association prend la décision
de le licencier
aussitôt porte plainte tout ça rentre
dans le calme et suit la procédure 2 ans
après l'instructeur en question gagne
son procès va au prudom fais un rappel
de 2 ans de salaire plus les indemnités
d' avoir cassé sa carrière ça a coûté
200000 € à l'association en question et
ça l'a mis par terre
donc on peut avoir un certain nombre
d'actions mais pas au-delà de ce que la
le le droit du travail trava d'un côté
et le le le le les préconisations
judiciaires de l'autre nous le
permettent et merci pour cette pour
cette anecdote on a pleinement on a
pleinement conscience de tout ça et
c'est bien l'objet des travaux de cette
commission que d'identifier non
seulement les dysfonctionnements mais
aussi les
limites les limites de pouvoir des des
uns et des autres et encore une fois
l'objectif il est vraiment de de de
faire uvre utile et et Infiné d'essayer
de trouver un chemin qui sécurise à la
fois les associations pour reprendre
l'exemple que vous que vous donner qui
peuvent être là aussi entre guillemets
victimes de ce que vous de ce que vous
dites mais aussi de de de trouver le le
même chemin qui va permettre de de
sécuriser toutes les pratiques sportives
et d'en finir avec les violences
sexuelles et sexistes et
autres autres fait d'homop phobie
racisme et cetera dont nous n'avons pas
parlé si si vous nous le permettez ou
quand vous nous le permettrez on on a
des demandes très précises pour pouvoir
mieux faire notre
travail alors juste avant avant de
répondre à à cette proposition et avec
plaisir monsieur Stéphane Mazar a une
question
oui ben ça va un petit peu dans ce sens
puisque j'allais vous vous poser la
question de savoir si pour vous c'était
compliqué justement de devoir gérer vos
responsabilités en tant
qu'employeur des procédures
disciplinaires donc des procédures
administratives parfois et
aussi la gestion de procédures
éventuelles au judiciaire avec une
temporalité dont on sait qu'elles sont
toujours très
différentes et ça fait un peu écho à
l'anecdote que vous avez indiqué et
peut-être au aux propositions que vous
pouvez nous faire je reviens sur le cas
dont vous nous avez parlé de cette
personne qui commettrait des
actes habuel que vous signalez au
procureur de la République procureur de
la République dit circuler il y a rien à
voir mais vous vous prenez quand même
semble-t-il vos responsabilités en
suspendant donc son son son titre
d'arbitre ou
d'officiel est-ce que vous êtes organisé
d'une manière telle qu'il n'y a pas de
risque que cette personne dont vous avez
suspendu donc ses fonctions d'officiel
bah puisse spontanément se retrouver un
weekend sur tel concours il est connu
des organisateurs parce qu'il avait
l'habitude de venir au préalable et il
s'autodésigne entre guillemets comme
officiel lors de cette compétition
est-ce que ça c'est possible ou est-ce
que votre système ne le permet
pas pour répondre à cette dernière
question sur j'ai envie de dire tout est
possible en tous les cas le système est
relativement fiable et informatisé
l'ensemble des officiels de compétition
déclaré sur une compétition quelle que
soit sa fonction président de jury
assesseur juge arbitre et déclaré donc
par système informatique et lorsqu'il y
a un changement entre ce qui est déclaré
et la réalité du terrain donc c'est
déclaré au moment du changement de
résultat encore une fois tout est
possible on n'est pas à l'abri
effectivement d'actes malveillant mais
en tous les cas le le le paramétrage
fait quand même qu'on on limite
fortement en tous les cas dans la limite
de ce qu'on peut mettre en œuvre la
participation officielle de cette
personne à la compétition de même pour
un cavalier qui ne peut pas participer à
une compétition s'il a pas sa licence de
compétition active en bon et du
FA je voudrais vous ajouter que il y a
deux types de compétitions les
compétitions officielles les
compétitions d'entraînement autant les
compétitions officielles on maîtrise
parfaitement les les les les les acteurs
autant les compétitions d'entraînement
ils sont au libre choix de de je de ceux
qui les organise donc il y a il y a il y
a un vrai sujet de cet ordre là il faut
également savoir que ceux qui sont en
contact en autorité auprès des mineurs
ce sont les entraîneurs qui amènent leur
Cabal dans ces compétitions là les les
officiels de compétition en réalité ils
sont là pour juger si la barre est
tombée ou pas et sil chronomètre a bien
marché ils ont pas de de de de de
relation directe avec avec les mineurs
ils sont ils sont en public devant tout
le monde en train d'officier donc il a
il y a une ambiguïé quand même
permanente dans tout
ça madame la Présidente est-ce que vous
me permettez de de reprendre la
parole je peux y aller euh on voit bien
que vous typiquement c'est une activité
qui est à la fois donc gérée par la
Fédération française d'équitation mais
il y a aussi une grande activité de
l'équitation qui se fait hors cadre
fédéral avec des des clubs privés et
cetera on peut très bien alors dites-moi
si oui ou non mais on peut très bien
imaginer une situation où quelqu'un donc
serait mis entre guillemets au ban d'une
féd parce que il commettrait des actes
répréhensibles mais la gestion de
l'équitation en
France n'empêcherait pas cette personne
de continuer à se retrouver avec du
public jeune dans le casadre d'une
activité équestre dans une structure
purement privée qui échappe à
l'organisation et à la tutelle de la féd
c'est c'est possible ou
pas bien
sûr bien sûr
et il faut bien il faut bien se rendre
compte que les établissements et caiss
sont pas tous affillés à la Fédération
et tout à l'heure je vous disais il y a
il y a il y a deux il a il y a deux
fonctions mais à l'intérieur de la
Fédération il y a il y a trois familles
entre pour pour identifier il y a ceux
qui font de la compétition il y a ceux
qui font du sport éducatif et de de de
d'activités physique et il y a ceux qui
font du tourisme et questest c'est ces
trois populations qui sont quand même
très différentes les unes des autres et
qui ont pas les mêmes besoins les uns
les autres d'adhérer à la Fédération les
premiers c'est obligatoire les seconds
s'ils veulent passer un Galot s'ils
veulent passer un diplôme pour statuer
le leur niveau il faut il faut qu'ils
soyent à la fin de la fédé dans le cadre
de la Fédération et les derniers pour se
balader dans la nature la plupart disent
nous on a besoin de rien et d'ailleurs
il y a d'autres organismes qui jouent le
rôle de fédération et qui les fédérent
aussi et qui sont qu' on pas de
délégation de de de l'État mais qui le
font aussi et un des grands enjeux de
ces 20 dernières années au sein de la
fédération ça a été de conserver l'unité
de ces familles là parce que on est
toujours en en en en en perspective de
voir à nouveau la Fédération s'éclaté en
fonction des différentes chapelles on a
32 disciplines différentes à l'intérieur
de la Fédération c'est pas une
discipline comme le football où tout le
monde est obligé de de se conformer à la
même règle donc la difficulté de tenir
la Fédération c'est de tenir son unité
justement pour mieux maîtriser tout
cela y a-t-il d'autres question c'est
bon donc ce qu'on va vous proposer c'est
d'apporter votre contribution écrite
avec les propositions que vous voudrez
bien faire évidemment dans votre
discipline j'imagine mais en tout cas
nous sommes à l'écoute et et nous vous
remercions par
avance merci
monsieur